Biden has not faced the same level of
scrutiny that Trump did if you if we had
Trump's family right involved in all the
nefarious acts that the Biden families
involved in do what Shady deals with
Dinah with China accepting money from
foreign Nationals
um all these shell companies
[Music]
yeah if all this stuff was associated
with Trump they would have buried him
further but you don't see the mainstream
media covering that with all the
nefarious links to the Biden
organization oh my God bro if it was the
if it was the Donald Trump Junior laptop
well under it would be over smoking
crack underage Chinese girls all the are
you kidding me bro